Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to
Cliff from Seattle. Cliff, you're on the air
right in the area. Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Awesome. Oh, cool. I didn't
really expect you and called on. I've been
a big fan of yours for a bit now. Thank you.
I was curious. We've had I live in Washington
state. As you can guess, our last election,
the one that elected Joe Biden. We also
reelected Jay Inslee and rather immediately
his big contender, the Republican candidate
started calling for saying was voter fraud.
There was massive voter fraud. And that didn't
seem to really go anywhere in this state like
it wasn't taken seriously by our people in the
state he lost by about, I think it was 60 percent
to 40 percent or so. But I'm really concerned that
I see this being the tactic, the standing tactic
that Republicans are going to use. Yes, they do.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. And I've spoken about this
before. Yeah. Jay Inslee defeated Loren Culp by
13 points in 2020. It was 50, basically 56 to 43,
57 to 43. And there were a few attempts from
Republicans to push the voter fraud thing. It went
nowhere because number one, there's absolutely no
factual basis for it. And number two, you know,
a 13 and a half point loss, it's going to be
very, very difficult to overcome in any serious
way. But as I've said before, this is going to be
it's almost becoming a meme at this point, which
is if we win, it was fine and if we lose, it was
voter fraud. We saw them lay the groundwork for it
earlier this month in Virginia, because remember
before the election for the Virginia governor
between Youngkin and McAuliffe, you started to
see like there was a Republican state senator
Trump and others saying, looks like the Democrats
are stealing it again. Young ended up winning.
They didn't say a word about it anymore. We won.
Why? There's no fraud. We won. So it's a very
dangerous precedent. And you're absolutely right.
Speaker 2: Yeah, and I don't know, I'm just
concerned of like what that's going to do for
from how to combat it, from the people that's
that, you know, agree with it and believe it and
how we can neutralize that threat from the public.
Speaker 1: See, here's the thing. For a lot
of these people, they don't literally believe
there was voter fraud. They believe that if
you want to demonstrate your bona fides and
commitment and devotion to the team, you say that
you believe there was voter fraud and it's a way
that you virtue signal that you're part of the
team. I think that for some of these people,
they don't actually believe it. They just say that
they believe it. It doesn't actually make it less
dangerous, though.
Speaker 2:
Yeah, I I agree it's I've I've got some family
that agree with that there was fraud and such,
and it's really frustrating.
Speaker 1: Do you think do you
think they literally believe it or
that they believe it's what you have
to say to prove you're on the right team?
Speaker 2: My impression is that they believe
it. OK, I guess I haven't really considered
that maybe it is a just another virtual
virtue signaling from the right.
Speaker 1: And either way,
it's disgusting and dangerous. I think
we're on the same page about that.
Speaker 2: Gotcha. Yeah, well,
I'm a big fan of the show,
and I really appreciate you taking my call.
Speaker 1: I appreciate it. Thank you so much
for calling in. Yeah, it's an important time.
It's part of this like they see themselves as
waging a war. And part of that is you've got to
show you're on the team. And so they say a lot of
things. They may not they may not literally
believe, but they might, but they might.